[Musique]
robin bonjour maurice fulton du préfet
de martinique dans le sens qu'a dit ce
matin pour expliquer les assises de
l'outre-mer des assises voulurent le
rappel par le président emmanuel macron
pour imaginer pour penser pour
réinventer l'avenir de nos territoires
franck robine cette idée d'assises
décliné sur chacun de nos pays
sérieusement pourquoi faudrait-il y
croit plus que tout ce qu'on nous a déjà
expliqué et excusez l'expression balancé
dans le passé
écoutez les assises de l'outre-mer et je
vous remercie d'en parler c'est
important pour la martinique pour les
martiniquais pour les martiniquaises et
moi j'y crois parce que ces dynamiques
et concret oui concret parce que la
méthode est nouvelle et se veut
résolument concrète c'est à dire que les
martiniquais sont invités à présenter
des projets très concrets dans un temps
limité qui est grosso modo celui de la
mandature c'est à dire 4 5 ans et
justement parce que c'est concret
illimitée dans le temps tout le monde
pourra vérifier que les engagements
seront tenus au moment où nous parlons
franck robine vous avez quand même
conscient que ces assises ce principe
des assises de l'outre-mer saïdi faire
beaucoup plus que cela ne séduit je ne
crois pas qu'on puisse dire cela et
d'ailleurs y est à quelque chose dont je
voudrais une félicité ce matin c'est que
ceux qui participent le plus à la
consultation
actuellement sur internet ce sont les
martiniquais ils sont deux fois moins m
2 fois et demie moins nombreux que les
réunionnais et pourtant ce sont les
martiniquais qui répondent le plus on a
un total de 36 mille consultations il
faut il faut toujours faire plus et
d'ailleurs je vous remercie parce que
c'est l'occasion de dire vraiment
martinique et aux martiniquais sq plus
nombreux nous serons plus les chances de
porter les projets de la martinique
seront grandes
brigitte girardin cela ministre d
outre-mer elle a eu quand même cette
petite phrase aux martiniquais et
guyanais réunionnais est là quand même
dit reprenez la parole ça peut être
jean d'entendre cela quand on sait que
nos politiques nos socioprofessionnelles
nos associations notre population de
cesse de dire de dénoncer ce qui ne va
pas dans notre pays écoutez c'est annick
girardin qui a dit cela effectivement
pas brigitte la ville est donc ce que ce
que vraiment ce que je veux souligner
c'est que le fait que les martiniquais
se soit emparé de cette consultation
qu'ils soient les plus nombreux à
répondre ça veut dire qu'il ya une
petite musique est en train de se faire
une petite musique positive en faveur de
la martinique
moi je rencontre des martiniquais comme
vous le soulignez qui parfois ont des
difficultés mais je rencontre ici
beaucoup de gens qui portent des projets
très concrets qui ont vite les choses
avancent donc il faut qu'ils ressortent
des projets qu'on connaît déjà qu'ils
sont enterrés dans certains endroits il
ya des projets nouveaux
lorsqu'on a tenu les assises de les
assises sur le tourisme on a beaucoup
parlé de la gastronomie en créole et
nous étions notamment avec le chef
marcel ravin qui est ce martiniquais
installés ou monaco qui est un chef
étoilé et il est très intéressé pour
soutenir l'idée qu' il y à une
gastronomie créole qui peut intéresser
des gens ce qu'ils peuvent attendre des
assises de l'outre-mer en 2017 pour
savoir qui l'a qu'il y à une gastronomie
martin écoutez je crois que c'est
surtout aux martiniquais aux
martiniquaise de dire quel projet ils
entendent pousser moi je me félicite que
les acteurs du tourisme le comité
martiniquais du tourisme
les responsables de l'hôtellerie veulent
pousser ce projet parce que ça permettra
de faire venir plus de jambes et donc
d'avoir plus de richesse des taux reste
donc ressortez les projets est ce que le
gouvernement est ce que l'état pourrait
s'appuyer par exemple sur les
consultations qui a déjà qui ont déjà eu
lieu on se souvient par exemple de celle
qu'a eue avec sous la présidence de
nicolas sarkozy l'est également par
exemple ces ces schémas de développement
économique portée par les régions comme
le stipule la loi
ça ne pourrait pas être une base de
départ tout simplement tout à fait mais
vous avez tout à fait raison mais
d'ailleurs comme vous le savez la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
est partie prenante ds
le président marie jeanne à juste titre
a insisté pour qu'on reprenne les
travaux qui avaient été faits le schéma
de développement économique le schéma
touristique
le livre bleu le livre orange c'est
l'association contact entreprises qui
est une association patronale ce qu'on a
déjà tout finalement tous mes
interlocuteurs me disais je suis
d'accord avec eux que l'analyse a été
faite et qu'il ne faut pas que ça soit
une énième analyse des potentialités de
la martinique mais c'est ce qui arrive
c'est ce qui agace ça peut vous
comprenez la population la population il
agacé une grand-messe de plus pour faire
croire et écoutez je pense que la
population participe en nombre ça je
voulais déjà dit et elle a des projets
concrets je vous prends un exemple de
projet concret encore un c'est celui de
l'école de la mer de la trinité ce
projet l'un cette école elle est
reconnue mais ce n'est pas encore un
lycée maritime donc qui qui qui peut
délivrer des titres reconnus on a le
souhait de lors des assises de faire en
sorte qu'elle devienne une vérité un
véritable lycée maritime délivrance vint
ce landais et dit souvent ça c'est pas
nouveau mais finalement franck robine
finalement d'autres cela ses
propositions ses projets existent
finalement ce n'est pas l'état ce n'est
pas le gouvernement qui est sourd à ce
qui a déjà été demandée le gouvernement
il a proposé une méthode c'est ce que le
président de la république et la
ministre de l'outre-mer ont proposé ils
ont dit aux martiniquais ou
martiniquaise emparez vous de cette
consultation venez avec nous au projet
et nous y répondrons et c'est ça je
crois que c'est une méthode nouvelle
parce que encore une fois comme c'est
dans un temps limité comme c'est concret
chacun pourra mesurer que les
engagements seront tenus
donc d'ici la fin de cette mandature les
martiniquais comme les guadeloupéens les
réunionnais mais elle et les guyanais
tout ce verrou concrètement des projets
sortir de terre oui je moi je le crois
parce que ces projets ils sont d'abord
proposés par les martiniquais eux mêmes
parce que les martiniquais ont des
projets ces jeunes de l'umih n'a par
exemple lorsqu'il nous parle de web tv
de l'outre-mer ils ont lancé maintenant
il veut le développer
et moi je vous donne rendez-vous
effectivement dans trois quatre ans je
pense que ce projet là et d'autres
auront eu une concrétisation de telles
assises pour avoir des conséquences des
effets sur ce que ressentent les
martiniquais au quotidien une incidence
sur la cherté de la vie sur le prix du
billet d'avion sur la téléphonie sur le
coup de l'internet sur l'organisation de
transports sur l'efficacité des
transports
vous avez tout dit effectivement les
assises ont vocation à traiter de tous
ces sujets là moi il y en a peut-être
que je place peut-être de façon
horizontale sur tous ces thèmes là c'est
celui de l'emploi je crois beaucoup en
portant les projets de formation que on
permettra un développement de l'emploi
et développement des qualifications et
que la situation de l'emploi
s'améliorait en martinique je crois pas
ce qu'il y a des atouts dans cette île
frac robbins et vous parlez des chiffres
de la consultation sur le site
martinique de ces assises de l'autre
mais vous savez certainement peut être
quelles sont ses sujets qui reviennent
le plus oui bien sûr alors il ya
différents domaines notamment les
transports et particulièrement les
transports publics
la formation on va bientôt faire une
analyse la 2d premier premières semaines
de consultations en tout cas les deux
domaines que je viens de citer les
transports publics et l'information sur
ce qu'ils ressortent le plus est ce
qu'on parle de l'attractivité de notre
chère martinique d'autres si belle
martinique est pour mons et sa jeunesse
là la martinique vous avez raison de le
souligner en fait elle a tous les atouts
vous pouvez voir une saison touristique
qui dure toute l'année ici
ça n'est pas le cas encore ce qu'on veut
c'est pas forcément que des des
touristes viennent et passent quelques
jours et repartons voudrait peut-être
que notre population se fixe d'avantagé
coin davantage en son pays oui tout à
fait vous avez des choses qui vous lu
récemment je visite est une entreprise
de formation qui s'est ouverte il ya
deux ans et qui désormais je forme des
jeunes martiniquais à l'installation des
fibres optiques pour le très haut débit
c'était auparavant impossible il fallait
aller en france se former et l'auto au
bout de quelques mois
u 9 personnes sur 10 trouvent
immédiatement un métier de venir sur le
casting sur le casting parce qu'on veut
quand même le rappeler frau comines ces
assises martinique seront des ateliers
une demi douzaine à peu près sur la
castine vous avez retenu pour présider
pour présider ces ces ateliers des
socioprofessionnels des élus
qu'est-ce qui les a choisis il ya une
consultation d'abord il faut être
volontaire pour mener des ateliers des
échanges avec les institutionnels vous
comme vous le savez nous copient
l'automne avec la collectivité
territoriale de martigny mais j'ai pris
soin de consulter évidemment toutes les
sensibilités de la martinique
les gens qui sont à la tête de ces
ateliers ce sont des personnes réputées
pour la connaissance des
socioprofessionnels des élus prg pas de
syndicat ils sont passés représentatif
de notre population alors j'ai prévu et
nous en parlions hier avec la directrice
des relations sociales la dieccte j'ai
prévu une consultation spécifique avec
les syndicats parce que je crois
qu'effectivement ils ont ils peuvent par
définition de participer à tous les
ateliers
je crois que c'est important d'essayer
de faire passer notamment une idée
peut-être l'amélioration du dialogue
social les voies et moyens pour que ces
syndicats et plus de moyens humains non
ils m'ont beaucoup parlé donc ça mérite
me semble-t-il un atelier spécifique en
aucun cas sonner secteur cette décision
d'ivoire principalement des socio
professionnels et des élus
le donc le les choix qui ont été faits
encore une fois ce sont des
personnalités réputées pour leurs
compétences pour ce qui me concerne
actuellement je rencontre l'ensemble des
syndicats généralistes de la martinique
pour faire ce point là et encore une
fois on va porter jeu parce que je pense
qu'aussi une voie d'amélioration très
concrètes
on va porter un groupe de travail sur
l'amélioration des relations sociales
c'est extrêmement important
j'en discutais d'ailleurs hier avec la
cgpme avec le côté patronal ce soir le
rendez vous c'est au clair d'un
allaitant abri quand on parlera de la
jeunesse a placé au coeur de l'évolution
de la société martiniquaise
le rendez vous c'est à 18h merci d'avoir
été ce matin avec nos franck robine on
rappelle que vous êtes le préfet de
martinique et que vous étiez dans son
caddie vous parlez des assises de
l'autre mère
[Musique]